sheriff Scott Israel would never blame
his own repeated failures for the
shooting at stun Stroman Douglas high
school instead he needed to blame an
organization that was not involved
the NRA during CNN's 1984's town-hall
meeting last week Israel played the
demagogue against NRA spokeswoman Dana
lash watch you just told this group of
people that you are standing up for them
you're not standing up for them
deena lash joins his sights Dana when I
was I was watching that my first thought
was he doesn't sound much like a sheriff
he sounds like someone running for
office a tammany politician a red-faced
blowhard a demagogue it doesn't sound
like something a law-enforcement
official would say in a town hall what
do you make of that I completely agree
with you Tucker and I'm so glad that
you're talking about this because this
is ultimately this is the failure and
this is where the failure took place it
was with this man in his leadership as
Broward County Sheriff and I'll have
everybody know Tucker as well before the
sheriff took that stage him and I
sitting up there for this Town Hall he
was allowed to go out and give a rally
style speech in which he railed against
special interest and was naming the NRA
and really setting the stage up to go
after five million law abiding innocent
Americans who didn't get all of the 45 I
think is what BuzzFeed reported tips
that his office received they didn't
have the murderer calling his office
himself telling him that he thought he
was a threat and that police needed to
do something family members weren't
calling the NRA reporting this they were
calling his office and so he has a lot
of explaining to do and one more quick
thing Tucker I asked the sheriff on
stage whether or not he could have
actually arrested this murderer based on
a Florida State statute that that
treated anyone sending electronic or
written threats of bodily injury harm or
death to other individuals as this
murderer did with his classmates whether
he could have arrested that individual
charged with the felony and the sheriff
did indicate that he could but then he
glossed right by it and wanted to
refocus and shift responsibilities away
from his dereliction of duty I think he
owes a lot of innocent Americans an
apology well but it's also really
troubling because I mean this is guys
not a congressman from Camden he has the
power to put people in jail to take
their lives away from them he's a law
enforcement official and this behavior
seems reckless and dishonest and weird
comparing yourself to Jay you know do
MLK and Gandhi I mean is it something
wrong with him and you know you
mentioned that that Game of Thrones
quote the lion doesn't worry about the
opinions of the Sheep well he mentioned
that again yesterday in a radio
interview with with the South Florida
station and he was attacking all of
those including the congressman that you
just had on the lawmaker that you just
had on
at the state of Florida who was calling
for his resignation and you know I agree
with you I I don't I wish that this
would have come out on the stage I wish
that this truth would have been known at
that particular time it seemed is that
he was more interested in turning this
into a campaign stop and I will say that
this really explains why the Coral
Springs police chief came out against
the Broward County Sheriff the way that
they did they said in a statement that
the truth is going to come out because
Coral Springs police reacted they were
the first ones in and they seem to be
really calling the Broward sheriff out
on what I can only assume to be
showboating was what they were
suggesting in their letter and there had
to be a lot of drama behind the scenes
for other law enforcement officers who
really I mean these are the guys who I
mean they they sacrifice they ran in
they heard the sound of gunfire and
screaming Tucker and they ran in and
they did what they could to save
innocence that's why we love our law
enforcement because of what they do for
us and now it's no wonder that they came
out against this bright this Broward
County Sheriff it's also transparent
though I mean I'm not blaming the shooty
with a shooting on the sheriff he didn't
commit the shooting but a series of
missteps by his agency allowed it to
happen
he's pulp well in some way and yet he's
diverting all the attention to others
it's the most basic and recognizable
kind of but covering why does the press
don't point that out I wish they would I
mean what we're talking about is
systemic failure here and Tucker I mean
here you had the 45 reports into the
sheriff's office you also had two FBI
reports but even bigger than that we've
had decades of the political class
ignoring the mental health crisis here
in the United States and politicians who
have refused to report dangerous people
who are been adjudicated unfit dangerous
to themselves or others to the next
system and so this is why we at the NRA
have been pushing for targeted action
and offering solutions on this and we're
going to continue to do so yeah so if
you run a city with tens of thousands of
mentally ill people living on the
sidewalk and you're lecturing us about
guns
you know maybe trying to wake up a
little bit Thank You Dana I appreciate
it